yeah let's celebrate
so I mean you gotta figure that guy he
did it right yeah he burnt the cow gotta
go I mean unless we buy the conspiracy
someone else did it or he set him up he
said he smoked weed on the couch there
is a little bit of truth to you know you
did invite the guy over and get him
really high and the guys like you know
known for doing that kind of thing so in
a way maybe kind of cinema like deserved
it a little bit maybe I know it was very
generous considering how much they seem
to not like each other he was a whole
new couch where he wants a brand-new
couch that's what he wants yeah and it's
he says it costs $1,600 but that was two
years ago there's no way that thing
called sixin
yeah yeah well I take this ball ramp I'm
gonna calculate appreciation over the
year two years there's a there's a
formula for depreciation but it's
Italian leather